listening to film courage women
a talk radio
I think an actor has to be honest you
know i'll tell you a story I was in I
was going to Zihuatanejo to Mexico and
our plane landed late and are we missed
our connection so I ended up with two
other guys stuck in Mexico City and one
of them was the chairman of the board of
William of william arce of the cigarette
company Philip Mars ok and the other one
was a lawyer and we're having dinner
that night and the lawyer said to me you
know it's funny I do the same thing that
you do i get up in front of people and i
try to convince them of something and I
said well you know really no I said the
difference is that you get up in front
of people and you you try to manipulate
the truth and I get up in front of
people and I have to tell the truth and
if I'm net not telling my deepest truth
is then I'll never be believed so I'm
being an actor is about telling your
deepest truth there are people who are
just blessed you know you see great
actors like Brando you know to me you
know brando is the the greatest and you
know that he was born with something
special that that wasn't just something
that he learned it was god-given